hey guys I'm Greg Alva with me is Evan
Dollard Evan Dollard Evan Dollard I met
up you saw the central intelligence
training videos we did were we on the
same team
oh that's a great one I think we were on
the same team I kind of blocked it all I
have pretty sure we were yeah but I
kicked the most ass according to the way
the video was edited yeah that's how I
remember that's how I am that's all
remember it yeah you guys haven't seen
that check it out when I workout and get
a shower I sweat a lot I don't know why
I'm that way just limp I thought you're
just nervous to be sitting as well oh
you are a beautiful man like the body go
on his Instagram Spartan man or what's
the what's the what's the way people
promote you I mean Spartan Ultimate Team
Challenge the show that I hosted I've
done five seasons of American Ninja
Warrior I can jump and climb on things
that's that's really all I'm good for
I'd be the elliptical for 30 minutes at
LA Fitness that's all you mean it's what
I do a lot of people requested that we
check out this HBO documentary reviewed
documentary trailers so we're the
Slenderman I have played the game
slender man he was talking about how
he's seen memes of Slenderman Slenderman
is a pretty popular thing I don't really
know the details of what Slenderman is
but some creepy thing in the woods just
appeared a creepy thing in the woods I
feel like it has its trump oh I think
it's kind of an urban legend like even
one of the guys from Ninja Warrior Jesse
la flair also on YouTube he did a
Slender Man video we're like getting
chased by hahaha just terrified that'd
be fun well let's find out what this
documentary is all about Evan Dollard -
okay he's moving the palest
like a seat pick it mandatory Street via
the night the Slender Man but he can do
what no one can came upon a 12 year old
female and if it be bad
what was bad damn why are you guys are
accused of stabbing the friend and
leaving her for dead
police say the suspects were inspired by
a character on a website Oh
faceless cool we never thought she could
possibly believe that it was real
families
to prove that Slenderman existed and
would be able to do that by killing
somebody how much it sucks to be a kid
know how to differentiate between
fantasy and reality people are
captivated by semi-matte hard and a
believe was real I really wonder if the
documentary is taking the approach of
this is real or this is fake yeah I
can't okay - that took a dark turn for
me I can't tell what like what exactly
position this documentary is taking a
stand not here
yeah what is the moral of this it got a
lot more real for me yeah when the
murder
yeah or attempted murder that's crazy
was inspired by like a boogeyman s
character that holy [ __ ] terrifying
that's more disturbing than I wanted it
to be I'm sorry the devil way to start
the weekend almost said now I need one
of those be here dude I'll get you I'm
not sick I've seen videos lately of like
how people are inspired by like movies
or something to commit like acts of
crime I don't know like the Slender Man
origin or mythology but something must
be up with these people who get
influenced by something that's
definitely artificial that's just not
that's like it's a game it's a it's an
herb it's a myth and then they're saying
it actually happen although although
maybe it actually happened maybe
Slenderman is real what you chew on that
pervert I prefer not to doesn't matter
how much working out you do Evan you
can't take down the Slenderman anywhere
from six feet to 14 to 14 feet tall do
we know how long this this idea I don't
know myth of the the Slenderman has been
around you know what let's uh let's type
it in all Wikipedia is why jump cuts are
helpful in a YouTube you know for sure
it'll start off as an internet meme
there you go
so 2009 stalking abducting
traumatizing people particularly
children working on a horror film right
now my buddy Josh and was watching a
handful of horror films we're watching
trailers for horror films in order to
kind of get in that mindset or decide
which ones to watch yeah in order to
that would contribute to the script and
there was one that was also a
documentary called how was it called it
was basically about sleep paralysis oh
yeah I remember seeing the trailer yeah
so I watched the trailer for sleep
paralysis and they talked about the
different figures that appear to them
while they perceive themselves to be
awake and they just can't move yeah
which I've had dreams like that where
you can't move and like you feel like
you're there's some sort of oppressive
thing happening to you which is
terrifying that calls into question what
is the reality like what how do you
discern between reality and fiction yeah
and the fantasy versus clearly when a
twelve-year-old believes so strongly
that she needs to prove the Slenderman
is real and and does so by committing
murder or at least stabbing that's
outrageous like where do you draw the
line between fantasy and reality and
what stories to tell and what stories
not to tell yeah
no I mean I just think all movies and
games should be PG oh yeah that's that
easy
that wasn't have any problems anymore um
all guns and video games should be water
guns way yeah that's super Mario had it
right that's about as violent as it she
get uh-huh no this other [ __ ] man this
is crazy stuff it's happening yeah I
don't like this at all although for a
twelve-year-old girl to be able to kill
she must be a tough woman hey you're
involved with American Ninja Warrior
Spartan races on dude telling you she's
a tough candidate she could be the next
American Ninja what did she get what is
she gonna do murder her way through the
American Ninja Warrior chorus I'm just
saying it's more of I'm up she's
intimidating to be only 12 and be able
to murder someone and sounds like she
murder an adult I'm telling you that's a
candidate right there I don't I don't
want any of it yeah so this doesn't seem
to be really about exploring who
Slenderman is it seems to be really
revolved around this trial of this 12
year old girl right I would like to see
a documentary that's more about like the
myth it doesn't sound like was even a
mythology of Slenderman it just sounds
like some dude made up some character in
2009
like some meme right all this happened
this is crazy
Wow I wonder who I can influence to
commit acts of crime is that the
takeaway yeah I can wonder I think her
what a character I could create I think
I look like a persuade people to commit
murder active yeah
back to savagery I think about 20% of
the demographic 20 to 30% of demographic
on here is under the age of 18 on my
channel oh really what that's what I'd
be curious to know I might just create
something and see how influential I play
then I'll run for politics because
that's how it works nowadays yeah an
internet name and in that name inspired
murder or attempted murder yeah that's
insane it was there I'm trying to think
of other means or every winchell like to
her mom like her mom BAE yeah I mean I
could get if you like watch the whole
film or something or there was like this
whole legendary thing but this is just
something so minor it doesn't make sense
how you could be so influenced unless
some adult came to this 12 year old girl
and like posed as something to like
freak her out yeah if that's the case
you gotta find that adult get him in
American Ninja Warrior I'm telling you
man you gotta mix things up to keep the
ratings going oh oh my gosh anyway guys
ninja warrior' homicide edition yeah
criminal edition it's a real American
right there they set up American ninja
there's no killing an American Ninja
Warrior instead of do the title like
prison edition yeah like prison it is
like you're combining Prison Break with
American Ninja Warrior be cool and
whoever wins gets a prison you start the
starting line you get a ship like that
not exactly navigate the observation
wasn't for this Slender Man documentary
trailer we wouldn't have come up with
the next great American Ninja Conte
you're welcome America welcome I voted
Hillary if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe a day become a reject Evan
what should I tell people to follow you
one and one is it the Internet but now
I'm terrified
so uh yeah Instagram YouTube they're
both Evan Dollard just my name they're
all in the description box go to there
now and shout out to um Slenderman if
you're out there I say we use your help
this guy's kind of getting on my nerves
oh I'm just saying he's too muscular has
to be stopped
I don't know there are worse things it's
stopping muscular that's not helping
this guy treated my why did you put it
on he was your mother